last night the fourth season of 90 day
fiancé
before the 90 days premiered and it is
gonna be a good season what has me so
excited it's the first time in 90 day
history the series will feature a
same-sex couple you want to say I I'm in
love with somebody from across the world
and that somebody is a girl Stephanie is
a social-media influencer from New York
with a YouTube channel of over 350,000
subscribers
she has fallen for a female Australian
photographer Erica as we have come to
know and love about the series their
love will not come easy Stephanie
actually has a bone marrow disorder that
makes travel dangerous I'm worried about
you
I don't think it's safe to go with my
health condition a common cold can kill
me it's a such a risk
why are you doing about her sexuality
Stephanie told the New York Post that
she has dated women in the past but
those relationships would fizzle out
saying I tested coming out to my mom a
few times by joking that I was done
dating men but she never took it well
that pushed me further into the closet I
think being on the show was like finally
ripping the band-aid off everyone has
their own coming out journey and both of
these women actually broke up with their
boyfriends to be with each other we'll
have to wait until next week to see how
their love story unfolds but we did get
a sneak peek at the couple meeting face
to face for the very first time
but I'm not sure if I really know the
real haircut so if you're like me you're
probably wondering what has taken the
series so long to feature a same-sex
couple
well TLC president and general manager
Howard Lee told time we've been actively
searching for a same-sex couple since
the series began but for various reasons
from visa delays to scheduling conflicts
to cold feet it just hadn't worked out
yet until now we are so excited to have
found Stephanie and Erica and welcome
them to our 90-day family so exciting
I love 90-day fiance are you excited for
next week's episode where we get to meet
Stephanie and Erica 90 days first
same-sex couple from the premiere which
couple do you think has a shot at love
and who is headed for heartbreak what is
the craziest thing you've ever done for
love let me know in the comments below
oh hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos